hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in his book
Anarchy state and utopia Robert knows it
devotes a portion of one of his chapters
to a thought experiment that has become
quite famous in part because it's a
really great way to think out some some
issues about what it is that we human
beings desire what the good life looks
like for us and what we would pursue as
a means to it and it's called the
experience machine now it actually
includes a sequence of machines
primarily focusing on this one that he
calls the experience machine but also
including a transformation machine a
result machine and as he says we could
imagine a whole sequence of other
machines as well
each of these is imaginary this is a
thought experiment nobody's saying that
these exist in reality we can find
correlates you know some people would
say well isn't that like being in the
matrix well the matrix is imaginary -
isn't this like immersing yourself in
some sort of virtual reality well yes
you're closer to that but we do exit
virtual reality and right now we don't
have smell-o-vision and you know the the
touch stuff that we have is still pretty
primitive so we're not quite at the
level of having the experience machine
you have to imagine this and this has
been you know imagine
not just by nose dick but you can find
it in speculative fiction as well so
what what is the the thought experiment
really about he says he begins this this
little section by saying there's
substantial puzzles when we ask what
matters other than how people's
experiences feel from the inside and
that's when he brings up this machine so
they're there people who are saying what
really matters is how people view things
how people feel about things you know
maybe the memories that they have to
draw up on and he says suppose there was
an experienced machine that would give
you any experience you desired
SuperDuper neuropsychologists could
stimulate your brain so you would think
and feel you were writing a great novel
or making a friend or reading an
interesting book now of course the
typical professorial stuff you know you
don't have to stop there imagine the
greatest meal you could ever have or
imagine a whole bunch of kind of boring
meals leading up you know in a
progression to better and better and
better meals you can you can structure
the experience any way that you want to
you could think about what would it be
like to have that first kiss and all the
excitement that went with it and the
anticipation and hopefully it turned out
good for you and then like have that
experience over and over and over again
you know or what would it be like to
take the body that you currently have
and imagine that you would have
experiences physical prowess that only
super athletes could have well you could
program that into the machine and we can
go on and on and on other could be
actually some quite you know gross and
degrading and terrible things to imagine
I won't go into any great thought
experiments but imagine doing some
horrific act that you know if society
even knew that you desired it you would
be shunned by everybody well I could be
programming into the the experience
machine just as well so you can make it
give you any kind of experience you want
if you want to have terrible experiences
if that's you know what you get off on
you could you could do that
- or you could have a mix of both you
know you could have as detail the
composition as you like so here's the
question he asks should you plug into
this machine for life pre-programming
your life's experiences now before we go
on and look at it let's think about that
for a minute
think about all the crap that we go
through all the wasted time all the
stupid we didn't learn anything from
this experience kind of lessons you know
they joke about that and television
shows now because you know they become
very self conscious about the fact that
there's supposed to be some sort of
lesson coming out of things maybe there
should be maybe a truly meaningful life
would be set up differently than what we
have right now so imagine you can set up
your life any way that you want
should you not just could you
psychologically should you is this a
sort of ethical imperative plug into the
machine or should you not plug into the
machine or should it just like be
totally up to to you kind of random
there you still have to decide whether
you should or not he says you know if
you if you're worried about some things
here's how we can address those if
you're worried about missing out on
desirable experiences just imagine that
business enterprises of research
thoroughly the lives of many others so
you know think about what it's like to
enjoy the lifestyle of the super-rich
you know stay piloting your yacht to
Gibraltar I don't know where rich people
go you know because I'm not a rich
person but we can imagine that so there
could be like all these scenarios that
could be provided to us by doing
essentially a kind of market research
thing and that would go into the the
Machine and you'd like pick and choose
well I'll have one of those and one of
those and one of those you can pick and
choose from their large library or
smorgasbord as such experiences
selecting your life experiences for that
say the next two years and then you can
revise
he says after two years have passed
you'll have ten minutes or ten hours out
of the tank to select the experiences of
your next two years so you could say
well you know that was pretty good but I
think I want to like you know now I want
to like see what it's like to be a monk
in a monastery for the next two years
that'd be cool as well and so you could
try out anything that you want and he
says of course while you're in the tank
you won't know that you're there you'll
think it's actually happening
that's the nature of these experiences
others can also plug in to have the
experiences they want so you don't have
to have to stay unplug to serve them
like you know children or you know aged
parents or spouses or anything like that
we all we all have our own little tanks
and who knows maybe they could actually
he doesn't suggest this maybe they could
be linked up so we could have like
virtual visits with each other
or something like that wouldn't that be
nice and then he says would you plug in
oh no so here's where we get to the crux
what else can matter to us other than
how our lives feel from the inside what
can matter to us other than the
experiences that either we're having or
about to have or had in the past and
then can remember is there anything else
he also says put aside another worry
don't refrain because of the few moments
of distress between the moment you've
decided in the moment you're plugged in
because after all what's a few moments
of distress compared to a lifetime of
bliss if that's what you choose and why
I feel any distress at all if your
decision is the best one so it was a
good question would you plug into the
machine I think for a lot of people
whose lies were sufficiently crappy or
frustrating or meaningless I think they
probably would say yeah definitely even
knowing that what they're doing is
plugging themself into something that's
a facsimile of life rather than actual
life when they talk about for example
Second Life which is one of the early AI
things which is still out there
apparently that is in a certain sense
life with quotes around it you might say
all right there's first life with a
capital L which might be
happy and then there's Second Life which
is a truncated experience but now we're
saying it won't be truncated it won't be
cut off it's gonna be just as full just
as rich as the life that you're
currently experiencing right now as far
as the experiences go
so Nozick says what does matter to us in
addition to our experiences here he has
three important considerations and this
is where you want to think do I agree
with this do I not agree with us that
would probably determine whether you got
into the machine or not so he says first
we want to do certain things not just
have the experience of doing them in the
case of certain experiences it's only
because first we want to do the actions
that we want the experiences of doing
them or thinking that we've done them so
you know there's some things that I've
brought up the first kiss thing so
imagine that your entire life of sex
intimacy desire all that sort of stuff
would be totally mediated through an
experience machine you would never
actually kiss another person it would
only feel totally realistically like you
had that experience and then you know we
would quickly move on from the you know
for so many people
landmark of losing your virginity into
the much more fun stuff of once you
actually know what you're doing doing
all those things right getting
introduced to new experiences trying out
variations would you want that or would
you prefer to actually do something
what about cooking and then eating
afterwards there's a really famous scene
in the movie The Matrix where the one
character who's told everybody out says
you know I know that at the steak that
I'm gonna be eating is not real it's
just numbers basically but man I want
that steak because he's not getting it
in the world that he's currently in
which is a crappy world right world
that's that's effectively run by the
machines except for where the resistance
has curved out little places for
Humanity
what about the experience of like
learning how to cook things and working
with real materials that to some degree
present you with challenges if you've
ever done any real cooking you know not
just pouring things out of boxes and
adding an egg in oil and some milk and
then stirring it up but actually cooking
things from scratch you know that you
have to you have to like engage with the
matter that you're working with and then
the actual eating of it do you want to
just have the experience or do you want
to actually do that so that's you know
that's another important consideration
and he asks the question he says why do
we want to do the activities rather than
merely to experience them he doesn't
answer that there he leaves that open
for you second thing we want to be in
certain ways be a certain sort of person
and he says someone floating in a tank
is an indeterminate blob there's no
answer to the question of what a person
is like who's long been in the tank is
that person courageous kind intelligent
witty loving or are they the opposite
are they stupid generate mean
egotistical cowardly he says it's not
merely that it's difficult to tell
there's no way that that person is here
he says something quite quite a strong
claim plugging into the machine is a
kind of suicide it will seem to some
[ __ ] by a pleasure that nothing about
what we are like can matter except as it
gets reflected in our experiences he
says but why should it why should it be
surprising that what we are is important
to us why should we be concerned only
how our time is filled but not with what
we are and we might say who we are what
kind of people we are and I think that's
a very strong consideration there can
you within a virtual reality really
become a person who has a certain
character you can express your character
and there may be ways in which virtual
reality could improve or worsen our
character in limited ways facing us with
certain kinds of scenarios and
temptations and perhaps guidance as well
but could we really
be a virtuous person or vicious person
in the way that we are in the real world
the third consideration he says as human
beings we actually and now this is quite
debatable we actually want contact with
a deeper reality there is no actual
contact with any deeper reality though
the experience of it can be simulated in
the machine and he says the plugging
into an experience machine limits us to
a man-made reality and somebody might
object at this point well I'm in wait a
second here what we've got a eyes and
they're pretty smart and you know we
could have a eyes like designing a eyes
which then would design the experiment
it would still ultimately be man-made or
human-made
right it would bear the artifact shoe
ality of the human even if it winds up
being a little bit weird and and beyond
us and you can say well what's wrong
with with human-made reality I mean
music is to a large extent a human made
and discovered reality and think about
how cool that is
right and we could go on and on and on I
may mention cooking cooking takes raw
materials and transforms them but this
is a little bit different this is you
know turning it into something that's
only the experiences that can be
provided there and he says you know a
good example of this is psychoactive
drugs some people view these as mere
experience machines you know you take a
drug and you have this kind of
experience from it and it might be
something that you can't have in your
ordinary life like for example taking
ecstasy might make you feel differently
about other human beings bodies and you
can get closer to them and not be turned
off by them smoking pot will have
certain effects you know amphetamines
will have other effects things that
actually make you hallucinate will have
other effects obviously but it's all
basically just it's instead of being
human made it's just made by the drug
others seem to see drugs as gateways
does he says avenues to a deeper reality
so you know how we view them determines
whether we want to be having that sort
of I won't say experience because that's
part of what we're debating here but
that sort of effect so he says we learn
something matters to us in addition to
experience by imagining this experience
machine and then here's the key step
realizing we would not use it but then
he says we can go a little bit deeper we
could imagine more machines to deal with
the fact we want a B in a certain way
what if we had a transformation machine
that would make us that kind of person
this has been thought about in other
formats what if you could take a drug
that would turn you into a good person
and not just a good person where you're
like you know your desires have been
essentially cut off and you're almost
like a robot no you would be a genuinely
good person you've opened to the world
and you know connected with people and
animals and everything else and you walk
along and you're like oh let me help the
old lady across the street because I
love doing this sort of stuff right if
you got a machine that could transform
you in that way should you use it before
you and here's the interesting thing you
would use that before you would get into
the experience machine according to
Nozik and that would solve the problem
of wanting to be a certain way right he
also talks about a result machine and
this is quite interesting here we go
is it that we want to make a difference
in the world consider them the result
machine which produces in the world any
result you would produce and injects
your vector in point into any joint
activity meaning that it like you know
the contribution that you would make
anything that other people would do it
would automatically do that without you
having to be there so like you know the
group assignment you don't have to
actually show up at the library to work
with the other people you just have the
result machine and it does that that for
you so he goes on and he says we're not
going to pursue here the fascinating
details of these or other machines there
is something to stir being about
something that's problematic he says
they end up living our lives for us now
that's an interesting idea they end up
living our lives for us so somebody's
living our life but it's not us we're
just experiencing it we're just along
for the ride we've lost a kind of agency
we've lost the anxieties that come up as
existentialist say when we have to you
know decide for ourselves and decide the
criterion by which we decide we've lost
other things as well in the process and
something is living our life for us but
it's not really living our life because
it's just a machine it doesn't live as
such and here he has a really brilliant
way of saying this he places it as a
suggestion that you can think about he
says perhaps what we desire is to live
and then he puts that in parentheses an
active verb living is not just like
anything else living is an activity and
he says to live ourselves in contact
with reality so there's two components
to that one is being in contact with
reality and not just something that's
that's human manufactured and there we
could debate well aren't humans part of
reality ok there's there something there
but live ourselves to have not just the
experiences but the involvement in the
production of those experiences to some
degree to be you know for better for
worse involved in it so this is quite an
interesting thought experiment packed in
there and it's well worth thinking about
yourself would you get into the machine
would you not get into the machine more
importantly why why wouldn't you why why
would you what is the reason behind that
because to make reasonable decisions
that too seems to be part of what it
means to be a human being
you